let's consider a kinematics problem and
in this problem we want to focus on
special conditions how to think about
that so what I'm going to consider is
some charge plates and I have a charged
particle and it enters into this region
of charge plates and in this problem
there's two types of forces that are
going to act on this particle there's a
gravitational force down and we're gonna
talk about some constant force upwards
whose magnitude is changing in time and
what I'd like to do is know what type of
how strong does this force have to be
this B is a constant in order for the
particle to not hit the bottom now let's
think about a little when we get started
on a problem like this there's a number
of different issues that we have to
think about the first issue is that how
do we even sketch what we think will
happen here well that particle enters at
time T equals zero so this force is
initially zero when the particle enters
so the particle is experiencing
gravitational force and we should expect
it to move start to accelerate downwards
but then this force is increasing in
time and so in a certain point these two
forces will balance and the particle
will have no net force up and gradually
this force will increase so the particle
will experience a force up so we would
expect some type of motion where the
particle starts to go down but now it's
starting to feel that force upwards and
it starts to maybe move upwards like
that so what I've done here is I've
sketched a trajectory of the motion to
help me think about the problem